all right um well we've got one
incredible teen who just made aviation
history this story moves me so much okay
cnn reports 19 year old zara rutherford
has become the youngest woman to fly
around
the world
solo this brave young pilot spent
260 hours in flight with stops in 41
countries for a distance of 32 000 miles
she faced weather
visa delays stuck in alaska and russia
got banned from china's airspace but for
five months she did this wow and then
she landed full circle to her home in
belgium her first stop was her favorite
sandwich shop a girl after my own heart
you're like
changing the world and breaking records
but you're still thinking about that
hometown sandwich
can you imagine
your friend your sibling anyone you know
accomplishing something like this she
she was over siberia and the winds were
so crazy she was scared like it was her
most fearful apparently she flew over
the atlantic and the clouds were so bad
she had to fly
1500 feet above water wow for nine hours
straight
what type of bravery this zara you are
literally my hero yup
keep it and what
what will she do next that's exciting
and what will she do next we got our eye
on you well next up this tick tock is
going viral for take a very strong
stance on engagement ring etiquette the
independent reports madison wright the
founder of madberry jewelry posted this
short but very clear message about what
to do when you're going to propose
this is a message for everyone who will
propose one day
the ranks should not be a surprise
but how and when you propose should be a
surprise
[Music]
so okay if the wait i want everyone to
weigh in on that right
uh agree you should pick the ring
together raise of hands
what are your names may i ask yes i'm
lisa and val motula this is my valentine
his name is valentine oh wait your real
name is valentine yes yes yes oh i love
you that was my dad's going back five
generations oh but his birthday is
february 16th he'll be 65. on february
16th oh wow
so i always have my valentine with me
35 years and we picked out the ring
together but he surprised me with it
a couple weeks later because it was
being made yep so i didn't know yeah
yeah so so this is my best friend the
thing about what we did is good advice
because planning ahead planning together
is part of a strong marriage but keeping
surprises in there is the other part yes
agree
agreed true
my heart is like a cartoon right now
i mean if you anyone wants to disagree
after that a show of hands
well i'll disagree a little bit with you
because because i i do agree that like
you shouldn't spring the ring right it
shouldn't be a total surprise but i
there should be a little collaboration
but there needs to be the essence of um
secrecy like for example when i proposed
to wellie i did the thing where we were
in a mall and i was like oh you want to
go like a jewelry store and like laugh
at jewelry
oh i hate that i like that you like that
you like so i kind of got some intel but
he didn't know i was gonna like pick we
didn't pick it out together because i
wanted to surprise him i i wanted to you
know knock him off his feet a little bit
so i love the idea that you guys
collaborated and then there's the the
engagement is surprised but
i wouldn't want to see the ring before i
want you to get my essence and then
figure it out i don't think there's a
right or a wrong there's no it depends
on the person like um i know wellington
wanted me to pick it and design it but
if someone were proposing to me you
better believe i'd want to pick that
ring out first
you better believe there you go
[Music]